My name is Wei Hou Wu.
I'm a computer science
major and my project
is a model to investigate
privacy preferences,
expectations, and behaviors
of voice-activated devices.
Now with the advent
of smart devices,
our constitutional right
to privacy in the home
is no longer protected.
That's why you have
headlines such as these.
Researchers in the
past have looked
into the technical
vulnerabilities of smart device
for privacy leaks,
but they've never
looked at it from the
perspective of the consumer.
The most they've done is
to look at consumer reviews
or interview consumers after
they've already used devices
for long periods of time.
We seek to take
this a step further
and introduce the model
based on a variation
of in-home contextual
interviews.
So what we want to do is get
voice recordings of the seconds
around when the user
activates this smart device,
in this case, the Amazon Echo.
To do so, we put a recording
device next to the Echo as well
as I have a whole host
of background processes
that helps in allowing
the experiment to be
within ethical guidelines.
Now once we have
these recordings,
we send the user a survey
containing these recordings
so that the user can replay
what the recordings contain.
Now the key difference here
is that these recordings
give the user a
full picture of what
is happening at the time of
their usage of the device.
As such, we can get good
informed reflections
on their usage of the device.
Now we've only trialed this on
a couple of participants so far.
It's far from perfect there are
still some improvements needed
for the robustness
of the setup, as well
as volume of data per day.
I'm proud to say that the
model works in giving us
this unique perspective
of user privacy
preferences within the home.